should tell you what's hard to listen to
though is that is that you will say that
about like the trauma or whatnot but if
I say to you I don't think women are
safe walking home late at night or
whatnot one first of all you're quick to
put it on me and I should move and I
should do this and I should do that but
at the same time you're not really
addressing where I'm coming from because
you're quickly saying yeah
you're almost I'm saying based on the
words that come out of your mouth yeah
you blame men for a thing yeah and I say
why don't you take accountability and if
you are feel unsafe walking home alone
why don't why don't you live somewhere
else because I I believe in taking
personal accountability for where your
life is and for me I don't you see where
I'm at I don't live in the best area but
I made sure I lived in a place with
security so I could feel safe but you